we're in ascalon just a few miles from
the uh the border fence
with gaza and in the last few minutes um
a real ratcheting up once again
of the the violence here and in gaza
a few minutes ago there were multiple uh
rockets
flying over our heads heading up towards
tel aviv hamas had said that they would
uh strike tel aviv at nine o'clock at
local time this evening
and so they have done just that what is
not clear is whether any of the rockets
made it through the iron dome
israeli missile defense system which we
saw being deployed behind us here
in um with numerous uh missile defense
missiles going up into the air to shoot
down those hamas rockets
that were flying overhead so the air
raid sirens have been very constant here
uh in ashkelon through the course of the
day and over on the other side
in gaza uh the um the bombardment by the
israeli military which has
prompted this new um counter-attack by
hamas on tel aviv the bombardment has
been
absolutely huge a 13-storey building
in the heart of of gaza collapsed this
afternoon
under the the weight of the israeli
military air force
strikes as you say 27 people so far
in gaza have died among them nine
children
here in israel two people have died an
elderly woman and her carer
here in ashkelon we were at the house
where they they died a little bit
earlier on a house that has been
uh comprehensively destroyed but the
dispropor disproportionality
of what is going on here i think is what
will alarm uh many people
uh the the large-scale destruction uh
over on the other side a few miles from
here in gaza compared with
uh yes very very frightening moments and
you know we just experienced it now as
the air raid sirens
started it is something the people of
southern israel
experience quite a lot they understand
that they need to get to the airaid
shelters uh it is clearly very
frightening here but the level of
destruction
on the other side as israel counter
attacks
is on a different level altogether
okay uh mark in israel thank you very
much mark stone there with that breaking
news hamas has said it has fired 130
rockets towards
tel aviv and its suburbs